If you multiply the
expression of U to any psi K and use the orthonormality of the vectors, you'll get a sum in which
all of the terms are zero
except for one of them, and the one term that we're
left with looks like this.
Now we can define the
phase estimation problem.
The problem is a little
bit unusual as we'll see.
We're given two things. First, we're given the description of a unitary quantum circuit,
that acts on N qubits
for some choice of N, and when we say that this
is a unitary circuit,
we just mean that all of
the gates are unitary, so there are no measurements
in this circuit.
Second, we're given an N Qubit state psi, and that's the unusual part.
We actually have a quantum
state input for this problem, and it's a single copy of this state.
For all the other computational problems we've talked about in this series, the input has been classical, either in the form of a string
of bits or as a black box.
And that's not surprising because the computational
problems that we encounter in our daily lives tend to be classical,
'cause those are the
problems we care most about.
The way that you can
think about this problem is that it's something that appears or is likely to appear as a sub problem.
And the phase estimation procedure we'll eventually come up with is something that we
generally use as a sub-routine
inside of some larger computation, presumably one for a classical
problem that we care about.
Now, this is going to be a promise problem and the state psi isn't
just any old quantum state.
We're promised that psi is an eigenvector of whatever unitary operation U it is that the given circuit describes.
And the goal is to find or
approximate the eigenvalue that corresponds to the eigenvector psi.
Let's state the problem a
little bit more precisely.
The input consists of a unitary
quantum circuit on N qubits, which can be encoded as a string of bits
using whatever method we prefer for encoding quantum circuit descriptions, along with an N Qubit state psi.
We can call the circuit whatever we want, but what really matters in terms of the statement of this problem is the unitary operation itself
that's performed when the circuit is run, and that unitary operation
is described by the Matrix U.
But we're not given U as a matrix, we're just given the description of a quantum circuit that implements U.
The promise, as I've already stated, is that psi is an eigenvector of U.
So if we ran our circuit on psi, we'd get psi coming out multiplied by whatever the eigenvalue is,
which would be a global
phase in that situation.
And finally, the output of the problem is an approximation to the eigenvalue corresponding to psi, and specifically we're looking for
an approximation to the real number theta, between zero and one, including
zero, but not including one
that satisfies the equation
that we have on the screen.
To explain this way of
parameterizing the eigenvalue corresponding to pis, and also to clarify what we mean by an approximation,
let's draw a picture of
the complex unit circle.
We can put the numbers one, I,
negative one, and negative I in their usual places and we can consider
some arbitrary point on the
circle parameterized by theta as we have in the problem statement.
This is the point we
get if we start at one and rotate by an angle of
two times pi times theta, so the angle isn't
theta, it's two pi theta,
and another way of thinking about it is that if we start at one and we travel a distance of two pi theta on the circle itself,
we'll get to our point, E to
the two times pi times theta.
Every point in the complex unit circle can be represented in this way
for a unique choice of theta.
And that's because we go
all the way around circle as theta goes from zero to one, and if we went all the
way to theta equals one,
we'd be back where we
started at theta equals zero, so that's why we include zero, but we don't include one.
Just to make sure that each
point on the complex unit circle corresponds to a unique value of theta in the range that we're considering.
There are various ways
that we could imagine approximating a particular value of theta, but the way that we'll do it is to approximate theta with a fraction,
where the denominator
is two to the power M for some choice of a positive integer M, and the numerator is an integer y
between zero and two to the M minus one.
You can think about this as an mbit approximation to theta if you wish, and we could write this
number in binary notation
where we have a binary point followed by the binary
representation of Y.
I say binary point by the
way rather than decimal point because decimal means base 10 and I'm talking about base two
here, but it's the same idea.
But in any case we can
also just think about it as a fraction like it
appears on the screen.
And to be clear, when we think about
approximations in this context, it should be understood
that values of theta